[Musique]
et une idée qui ne devrait peut-être pas
plaire à tout le monde à commencer par
le député daniel mach du vin en can est
une idée originale est pour le moins
surprenante lancée par six coopératives
de montpellier ce projet réalisé en
partenariat avec des étudiants de
l'école supérieure de commerce agricole
et de l'industrie agroalimentaire de
montpellier il fallait y penser tout
simplement pascaline ariza philippe
menut c'est pas une question de
présentation on sait que pour ce qui me
concerne c'est une question de qualité
en petite bouteille comme des comme qui
dirait comme des biens pourquoi pas
étonné
de la bouteille quoi enfin de débouchés
la bouteille même
les puristes vont sans décoller les
papilles plus besoin de verres pour
déguster du vin la canette s'approprie
notre vin de pays d'oc décliné en rose
et blanc rouge sont nos comédies situe
rapidement son origine montpelliéraine
les étudiants qui ont travaillé pendant
huit mois sur ce concept l'ont voulu
moderne branchée fruité mais il était
primordial de rendre le vague un peu
plus accessible
donc il ya un côté très traditionnelle
du vin en france il nous fallait toucher
ces jeunes par un packaging novateur par
un produit qu'ils connaissent la canette
mais afin qu'il vienne s'engager
franchir un premier temps un premier pas
pardon mais relevé m objectif séduire
les 20 35 ans localement en france mais
aussi dans les pays anglo saxons déjà
consommateurs de vin de table en canette
pour les viticulteurs ce projet novateur
et fédérateur
à cette période de crise il est
important le droit de restructurer donc
à vos coopérative au moins au point de
vue commercial et le fait de mutualiser
des moyens autour de ce projet peut-être
un premier un premier pas très important
d'associer le lancement de 30000 kanaté
prévu dès le mois de mai prochain
[Musique]